la souveraineté des lander suspendu pour
faire face à la pandémie
jusqu'à présent l'état fédéral ne
pouvait imposer des restrictions
sanitaires à toutes les régions les
länder est en compétent pour décider eux
mêmes des mesures à mettre en place pour
leurs habitants c'est maintenant terminé
le conseil des ministres a adopté un
projet de loi destiné à harmoniser les
restrictions dans tout le pays une
réponse à la pandémie qualifié comme
étant plus cohérente et plus vigoureuse
par an qu'elle a merkel nous mettons en
oeuvre les mesures de freinage d'urgence
à l'échelle nationale si le taux
d'incidence est supérieur à 100 et que
la réglementation nationale doit
s'appliquer à l'avenir les mesures de
freinage d'urgence ne seront plus une
question d'interprétation car elles
s'appliqueront automatiquement pour que
les choses s'améliorent pour que nous
brisons la troisième vague
les consultations entre le gouvernement
fédéral et les régions ne suffisent plus
notre réponse à la pandémie doit devenir
plus vigoureuse et plus cohérente
couvre-feu nocturne réduction des
contacts fermeture des magasins pour que
ces nouvelles règles soient mises en
oeuvre
le taux d'incidence devrait être
supérieur à 100 pendant trois jours s'il
est jugé nécessaire pour engueuler à
merkel afin de combattre la pandémie
ce renforcement des compétences
fédérales n'est pas vue d'un bon oeil du
côté de la population
une manifestation à d'ailleurs eu lieu
pour protester contre l'adoption du
projet de loi
eh bien je pense que c'est terrible nous
venons juste de rentrer de la manif nous
sommes contre nous sommes descendus dans
la rue et je pense que c'est un grand
danger pour la démocratie
quand une personne décide ici de ce que
nous devons faire et de ce que nous ne
devons pas faire c'est très très
effrayant pour moi je pense que c'est
absurde au niveau national les régions
devraient défiler d'elle-même elles sont
les mieux placés pour savoir comment les
choses se passent et placer tout le pays
en confinement sous couvre-feu
je pense que c'est complètement exagéré
je ne sais même pas si c'est autorisé
par la constitution
mais pour anglet la merkel la priorité
de faire face à la troisième vague qui
touche le pays
certains hôpitaux sont dépassés par le
nombre de nouveaux patients
la troisième vague nous a clairement
atteint oui nous remarquons une
augmentation ces dernières semaines nous
avions moins de patients et remarques
ont actuellement une claire augmentation
la troisième vague est clairement là et
elle se fait sentir une troisième vague
que la chancelière allemande a qualifié
comme étant la plus dure depuis le début
de la pandémie
le pays a franchi le seuil des 3
millions de cas et compte presque 80
mille morts dus qu'aux vite 19